justamente Pelé nació en tres corazones
una pequeña ciudad después se fue abaorú
donde el padre del Don guiño jugaba
fútbol Tuvo una lesión muy grave a la
rodilla Lamentablemente tuvo que dejar
de jugar tenía dos hermanos Lucia que
vive con la madre de Pelé incluso que
está viva que tiene 100 años y en tu
soca que fue el otro el otro hermano de
él con ellos con ambos es decir ambos
salían a lustrar zapatos ahí a la plaza
de de baúl y jugaban fútbol eh era
conocido por el apodo de Dico Dico eh la
familia entera lo conocía como Dico
posteriormente un homenaje a un arquero
del Vasco dama de minas gerais que se
llamaba bilé y por vilé aparece el
apellido de Pelé que la madre rechazaba
no le gustaba mucho Bueno y ellos
después se vinieron a vivir él con
quince años lo trajo Valdemar un hombre
que era empresario de fútbol y un ex
jugador para el equipo del Santos y
bueno Y a partir de ahí cambia la
historia decir el nombre que se dedicaba
muy pero al fútbol Siempre fue una
persona muy dedicada incluso la primera
cerveza La vino a tomar cuando ya había
ya había jubilado en Estados Unidos
aparece Tomando una cerveza y yo no sé
si la propagando algo así pero fue un
hombre que se cuidó mucho durante toda
su vida era un atleta completo como te
decía anteriormente corría los de cien
metros planos en en diez segundos y
siempre Tuvo una preocupación muy fuerte
por el físico entonces por eso yo creo
que llaman poco también la atención la
forma en que Pelé se fue con cáncer al
colon que ya se había
diseminado por otros órganos importantes
tenía problemas respiratorios y estuvo
internado desde el día 29 hasta ahora
incluso luchando bravamente junto a su
familia y los reunía siempre e incluso
es más eh una de las cosas que lo lo
deja muy claro él llamó a sus nietos que
eran hijos de Sandra una señora que el
el una hija Perdón que él reconoció
después de una disputa judicial porque
ella quería ser famosa quería ser
concejal de hecho lo alcanzó y nada
verdad que tenía toda una una inquietud
por aparecer más de que la hija de Pelé
sino ocupar el nombre de Pelé otra hija
Flavia que también está con él también
él la reconoció también fue de un de un
corto relacionamiento con una una señora
que también falleció y también la
reconoció y está ahí con junto sus otros
cinco hijos y y bueno estos dos nietos y
todo el mundo reunido felizmente el
consiguió reunir a toda su familia
pensaba pasar la fiesta de final de año
en su residencia No lo consiguió
Lamentablemente pero está rodeado el
cariño incluso ahora las declaraciones
que hace la última que publica kell y
Cristina que es la hija mayor eh dice
que él le agradece ella le agradece todo
porque todo lo que ellos son se lo deben
a pelear y esto yo creo que es muy
bonito todos los gestos que ha tenido la
hija de Pelé para mantener esto en
reserva ahora se está hablando Ya del
funeral que iba a ser hecho el velorio
en el estadio de Vila
justamente se retiró del fútbol oficial
antes de irse a Estados Unidos y también
haya un preparado en Memorial en
necrópolis
que está ahí en Santos el cual peleé
compró una un Nicho desde el 2003